the death toll climbed dramatically
overnight after a powerful earthquake
shook iran and iraq more than 340 people
are confirmed dead most of them in Iran
about six thousand others are hurt the
magnitude 7.3 quake struck yesterday
along the border between the two
countries Holly Williams is following
the race to help survivors from Istanbul
Holly good morning good morning there
have so far been more than a hundred
aftershocks since the main earthquake
overnight according to Iranian media the
quake hit during a live TV interview in
Iraq jolting the city of Erbil and
reportedly sending shockwaves all the
way to the shores of the Mediterranean
Sea but the worst damage was around a
hundred and fifty miles to the southeast
across the border in Iran where people's
homes collapsed on top of them a wall
turned over one said this little boy
ever heard it fell on me the quake hit a
poor and mountainous area 70 thousand
people are now reportedly in need of
emergency shelter just as winter closes
in they're still searching for survivors
according to local media the quake
struck along one of many fault lines in
Iran a country where they've grown used
to deadly seismic activity in 2003 an
earthquake near the city of bam killed
around 30,000 people there are also
reports this morning of landslides
caused by the earthquake which could
hamper rescue efforts gale all right
thank you very much Holly Williams